You had a drinking thing for awhile too,
Huh?
Yeah.
That's,
that's one that,
uh,
that gets a lot of fighters.
Yeah,
it does.
Um,
but it's one that,
you know,
on that,
that,
that
it ticks me off and it don't,
it ticks you off.
Yeah.
How so you'd,
a lot of it was ran through to the hometown,
you know,
and the troubles that I,
that I got in with the,
um,
TMZ,
stuff like that,
you know,
look,
the incidents that happened were petty small,
and if it was,
it wasn't in Youngstown,
it would've never made news stuff that kind of happens like my shit.
No BB guns and in a four wheeler,
yeah.
I shot a,
a kid,
we were playing around.
I was taking care of them.
And this is the truth of this story,
taking care of them.
I was putting a,
a big lake in my backyard and,
uh,
I got the country boy.
I mean,
I want,
I went out and rented two excavators and some bobcat's and started putting,
uh,
the pond in this,
this guy I was helping out.
He knows how to run the excavators.
So I,
he needed work.
He had no money.
I was taking care of him and his kids over at the house.
He's,
he's working.
So long story short,
after about five days I come home and he's in the pond or lake just in his
underwear playing around.
I grabbed the BB gun,
I'm joking around with him,
you know,
cause we were shooting targets for a couple of days in between work and I shoot
him in the,
uh,
on the arm for 42 years old at the 41 years old at the time too.
So it wasn't a kid.
He gets out,
he's like,
ah,
you shot me.
And,
and uh,
he's crying about it and everything else and next thing you know,
he,
he's cool though.
He gets out of these,
it's on Facebook and he's Giggling,
laughing about it and he stays at my house that night.
His kids come over,
I'm feeding them,
we're having cookouts the next day and little things.
I don't know that I'm glad that I'm not involved in no more or I don't put
myself in that situation.
So He's,
he stays for two days after that at my house.
And uh,
his uncle comes there who worked for the sheriff,
the local sheriff's department and it goes,
hey,
is so on and so here.
And I said,
yeah,
he was,
I haven't seen him.
No.
And he goes,
okay,
listen.
He goes,
Kelly,
I'm coming here to tell you.
So that way the news,
the media,
everything else don't come.
He has a warrant out for his arrest and tell him,
you know,
if he comes back,
call us.
So he leaves,
I go walk it through the house and they come.
Brian comes down the steps and I was like,
do jetty,
get the hell out of here.
I was like,
I didn't know anything of this.
You having a warrant,
blah,
blah.
He goes over and passes out on my couch.
I call his uncle,
hey,
you want him?
He's here.
So he finds out,
he ends up running out of the house and they catch them,
you know,
that night or whatever,
they take him in,
he does two months and a county jail,
gets out,
takes his uniform off,
walks over to the sheriff's department,
Sheriff's department and presses.
Charges on you.
Yes.
For shooting with a BB gun.
And a buddy of mine who was there when it happened was video in it.
His girlfriends laughing in the background,
you know when it happened.
But that was,
it was just a video of it happening.
He'd sold it to a TMZ and next thing you know,
I ended up getting served or whatnot.
My attorney calls me also and it says,
Hey,
go down,
turn yourself in.
You know,
it's a federal assault charge.
Yeah.
Kinds of federal assault.
Yes.
Yeah.
And that was it.
And again,
it was all over money.
It was a drawn out case.
I'm supposed to have been beat.
And it turned to that over a BB gun,
but a guy and he said it was an assault.
So I always trying to get from you.
You got nine grand.
And it was supposed to,
when he filed a civil suit a couple of months into this,
the criminal charges are supposed to be dropped at that point because prosecutor
and,
and everybody knew that it was all about money.
So they ever going to drop the criminal charge.
They never did.
And uh,
it goes back in Youngstown,
you know,
I was out in the public eye and someone that people would eight,
they had it out.
They have
to for people to understand how big star you are in Youngstown.
I mean,
I remember at the time,
I remember reading stories,
see in news clips mean Youngstown's not a big place and other than ray,
boom,
boom man seen,
he's not a whole lot of like really famous people,
especially fighters had come out of Youngstown.
But you were a fucking giant celebrity in that.
Yeah.
And that was Kinda my,
my bad on that.
That's where I think the,
the fault.
What else?
Probably hard for you to recognize.
You're not even 30 years old.
Yeah.
All this shit is going on.
And it's true.
And I'm not looking for that as an excuse.
You know when I say it,
but it is true.
I looked,
I looked at myself as everybody else.
Right.
I think that was the issue
you hadn't recognized yet that you're in some weird place we have to watch.
I felt like if I go to the bar and somebody goes,
boy you Kelly Paulis been here three days,
he's a lush.
My argument was I got every right to be here just like you do.
Matter of fact,
I have more of a right.
You know,
I'm retired,
I've got my money put away.
You're probably drinking your weekly pay away.
That was my,
my thought processes,
thought process of that and it was probably wasn't right.
You know,
because the,
it comes down to is you are a big fish in a little pond and it's a small city.
And I think that by being out there,
I brought a lot on myself because of that.
It is what it is.
Unfortunately,
as an athlete,
you,
you can't do that.
And,
um,
so that happened over a period of time and the word got around and a lot of
anger,
you know,
you have some jealous,
some angry,
there's some who just didn't like me.
So just so much fun for them to gossip.
Yeah,
exactly.
Because what else is really not beating up young song?
I love it.
It made me who I am.
But if you really look up young Saunders not drained a lot to talk about besides
the fact that we do put out the most NFL players,
the per capita really?
Oh,
absolutely.
Youngstown does.
Why is that?
You think?
I don't know.
Is averages,
there's just some,
some bad ass dudes from,
from Youngstown and it is,
I don't know why.
I mean,
even the boxing part of it,
if you truly break down the five rural champs from such a small city and 36
years as,
as it came up with the other world champs besides the rate boom,
mass seedy area,
Roya Roya actually held the title in the same way class Ron,
the same exact time that Massey and he did.
You had Jeff Lampkin,
uh,
Greg Richardson.
And,
uh,
then you had a handful of other guys like rolling Cummings and fighters out
there that were making noise out of Youngstown,
that guy can cigarette cigarettey who fought Chavez and Comacho out of
Youngstown.
But,
um,
being at being at being there like that,
it brought a lot of attention and people who wanted,
wanted,
you know,
and there was a lot of angry people.
Was it weird growing up there and then becoming a famous guy there?
Yeah,
it is.
Because again,
you know,
you don't,
people will tell you,
hey,
when you get to that level,
when you wouldn't have rolled title,
Shit's going to change man.
And you're going,
yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
You think,
you know,
right?
Like you're going,
yeah,
I got what you're saying.
And then it happens and you win it.
And it's so true when they say overnight,
like you're not,
you know,
more,
like you're,
you can't be yourself no more.
It's a,
everything changes and it comes down to the person.
Even though if you don't want to change and you like living your life the way
you did two days ago,
uh,
fortunately you can't,
you know,
and it's,
it's a hard,
and it's something that
you got to learn how to deal with that.
That wasn't my choice though.
You know what I mean by that?
My choice wasn't to go out and act like a jack alone.
My choice was kind of just be me though.
And um,
you just did what you wanted to do.
I did.
And then it just became a big issue because you were a famous guy.
Yes.
And the,
another issue on top of that came to was where I could actually take the blame
for this.
And,
and I honestly,
Cam a lot of it came down to,
and everybody's different,
so I'm not,
I'm speaking for myself.
I trained my ass off when I trained,
you know,
I was a six,
seven hours a day type guy.
And,
uh,
that's what got me to throw as many punches as I did around,
you know,
and I was in great shape for every fight.
I sacrificed a lot of things.
I gave up a lot.
You know,
even starting from high school,
you know,
being in the amateurs and,
and just turning pro right out of high school,
I missed a lot of things.
My mentality was when,
you know,
I had time,
I was gonna,
I was gonna live,
I was going to live like my friends who were 19,
20,
2124 and that was the process of it.
Um,
I do believe though,
at a point,
especially after I retired,
that it got a little got a little out of hand.
Absolutely.
You know,
and I'm not going to be the person to sit here and say,
it doesn't,
you know,
it did.
I'm not naive enough to say that,
well,
you know better than anybody,
but the rumors were always that you were drinking a lot,
but,
and that was affecting your career.
It mailed to some point.
I don't think it did.
People say,
use the fact that Hopkins beat me and that was this.
That was the reason.
And that's why I retired so young and it wasn't,
it truly wasn't.
Um,
maybe some of this stuff I was doing,
especially as I got older in between flights to drinking.
I think that that could have,
that may have heard a little bit.
I don't think it was enough to make any significant changes in my career,
to be honest with you.
Um,
but you know,
who knows what that,
if I didn't,
we'll never know again,
but I lived up and do I got anything to regret about it?
No.
Do you still live in Youngstown?
Yeah,
we're on the outside in the suburbs,
you know,
is it,
I mean,
it's gotta be strange to have grown up there,
been a child there,
and then become an internationally famous world champion boxer and celebrity and
still stay there.
Yeah.
It's the world changes.
And you're still Kelly Pavlick and I think after I retired,
as far as some of the mistakes I've come to where I should have gotten out,
maybe come out here to California or go to a Newmont.
Yeah,
right.
I don't,
yeah,
we're working on it.
Plenty of room.
Yeah.